Nó này, mình làm tháng 18, tông tin từ bảo đất lắc,
cơ quan kể rất đều trà công an tình đất lắc của giá quy định phở tổ bị càn,
lệ mất 30% xin nămu nghìn chính trăm sống michin,
chú sạy i a giốt đất lắc để đều trà về hình vi lợ đảo chính đất tài sản.
Chứ đó, cơ quan công an nhận được đường tụ cao của quân gái ông mở VT,
xin nămu nghìn chính trăm năm 18, chú phần thủ dấu một thêm phố chiming
về việc bị giang lợ chính đảo tám 15 đồng.
Và cuộc đều trà, bước đầu công an rất định,
năm 18, bữa trung ông T đe dễ sạy a giốt tình bố 18,
hế tà đất đồng nghiệp để trung cao su và làm trang trạy.
Thông qua 1 quân hệ xa hội, ông T đặc trở làm quân về giang.
Qua trò chuyện, giang lợi có thể giúp ông T đe tình bồn đất đề mùa.
Tinh tưởng, ông T'é xa cho giang một phép một tỷ đồng về lo tụ tục mô đất.
Đến ngày 20 năm 18, hệ hủ trăm 20,
sau khi một đồng 18, hế tà đất đồng nghiệp của mưa dân ở thôn năm,
ông T'é đại lập dưới y quyền tình ra tòn bộ số đất này cho giang cho con,
khoảng lý giúp.
Đầu thằng chiến năm 18, hệ hủ trăm 20,
khi biết tình ông T'é đá qua đời vì COVID-19,
giang này sình ý định chính đọt tại sản.
Lối tượng gọi định cho con gái ông T'é,
bể chuyện tra cô còn nở tình bố đất tảm viện trợ đồng và yếu cầu chuyện khoản định trả nở.
Tinh lời giang, người con đặc gửi tảm viên năm triệu đồng,
buồn tảm viện trở tình nở và năm triệu chi phí sáng xe.
Sau khi nhận tiền, giang đã chiếm ra,
sử dụng lý trả nở ở bà tư sai cá nhìn.